the president contradicted the White
House description of how Comey was fired
he insisted he had already decided to
dismiss the FBI director before a Monday
meeting with the Attorney General and
his deputy other officials including the
vice president have said the president
followed the Justice Department's advice
margot Brennan's at the White House
Margaret good morning good morning well
White House deputy spokesperson Sarah
Sanders dismissed these inconsistencies
as simply semantics but she admitted
that she had never actually asked the
president whether he had decided decided
to fire Comey before he received that
recommendation from his Deputy Attorney
General he's a showboat he's a
grandstander president Trump said he had
decided to fire former FBI director
Comey long before Deputy Attorney
General Rod Rosenstein recommended he do
so oh I was going to fire regardless of
record so there was a rumor he made a
recommendation he's highly respected
very good guy very smart guy the
Democrats liked him the Republicans like
him he made a recommendation but
regardless of recommendation I was going
to fire a call me that conflicts with
accounts given by Vice President Mike
Pence and administration aides who
described Rosen Stein's advice as the
deciding factor President Trump made the
right decision at the right time and to
to accept the recommendation of the
Deputy Attorney General
he took the recommendation of Rod
Rosenstein the Deputy Attorney General
pretty quickly after I believe receiving
that recommendation the president made
the decision to let director Comey go
the president admitted the ongoing FBI
probe into his campaigns ties to Russia
was on his mind as he dismissed Comey
knowing there was no good time to do it
and in fact when I decided to just do it
I said to myself I said you know this
Russia thing with Trump and Russia is a
made-up story the president also said he
wasn't concerned about optics when the
day after firing Comey
he held an oval office meeting with the
Russian Foreign Minister at the request
of Vladimir Putin it was set up a a
while ago
and frankly I could have waited but what
difference does it make the White House
says it was misled when the Russian
state news agency released photos of the
meeting without permission
that same day mr. Trump also met with
the Ukrainian foreign minister an oval
office visit only revealed after the
pictures were posted on the ministry's
Twitter account last night president
Trump took to Twitter to portray both
meetings as a peacemaking initiative
remember it was Russia's military
intervention in Ukraine that triggered
those US sanctions that now both Moscow
and many US businesses would like
president Trump to lift scale all right
Margaret thank you